this is a production of cornell
university
okay so the brief i i got was to to um
talk a little bit about how trees
um deal with drought and water logging
and i suppose
from that first slide you might guess
that i have a little bit of an urban
bias and
you know both of these subjects are
rather broad
and uh in their own right so i hope to
give you a little bit of a flavor of
some of the work
that i've done in in this area
i hope that um we're amongst friends and
we can all
agree that trees enrich our lives
uh through a whole range of uh different
ways of course socially emotionally
physically uh economically in some in
some cases
uh but i think when we're talking about
the urban forest
we can acknowledge that there are some
fairly strategic challenges coming up
perhaps the urban forest can be
visualized at the moment
as as a sort of you know pool of trees
that might be
performing somewhat well but with the
the pressures
created as a result of climate change
and certainly a whole range of
pests and pathogen having their
migration accelerated
through climate change they also pose
rather significant
pressures on the urban forest so we get
that population of trees
shifting into sort of the realms of poor
performance and
ultimately through to tree mortality
so there's a whole range of um
sort of challenges that i think we need
to be aware of if we're interested in
in managing trees within the urban in
within the urban
realm of course when it comes to
the acquisition of water urban trees not
only have to deal with
the presence of if you like climatic
drought the lack of rainfall that might
be brought about through climate change
but it also has to deal with issues such
as
soil compaction so this this tree here
may well look like it's got
a rather extensive volume of soil to
exploit
but much of that soil will be compacted
to such a high degree that
the tree roots won't be able to uh
establish within that volume of soil and
so
the the real volume of soil that tree
will have
is likely to be much much lower than
what you might think
and of course soil volume matters this
uh photo taken by
johan osberg shows that you know those
internal trees which were presumably
planted at the same time
as the marginal trees are performing
really
quite differently than much much smaller
soil volumes
probably in isolated pits uh mean that
the size is is uh really reduced
and a lot of that is down to
availability
of water and soil volume more generally
i see those marginal uh trees
uh ha do have some shared resources so
so they they have much more extensive uh
soil volumes and they're performing much
much
better as a result of course some trees
seem to be able to cope with almost no
soil volumes these these are in
uh fig trees in hong kong and uh they
can sort of stick themselves to the wall
uh so
we shouldn't assume that every tree can
behave like that in actual fact
even those trees probably are rooted
into like a cavity
wall section so that they probably have
a little bit more soil volume than
meets the eye
well impermeable surfaces also
also of course have a lot of influence
over the
the way that trees can access water and
this is a
site in southern sweden these trees are
30 or 40 years old
they look probably half that age and of
course when you're planting
into tarmac like that uh it's little
wonder
they don't perform terribly well in fact
i'm amazed that they're surviving at all
so we have this sort of interaction
between
the you know the extent of the soil
and the volume of the soil and the
climate and this little escarpment in
north wales i think shows
that quite nicely we can
see that those trees in the center
that are on the sort of steepest parts
of the slope
uh have the the poorest quality soil
are suffering most extensively from the
from the drought in that particular year
and those trees around the margins
higher up on the escarpment where the
soil might be
just that little bit thicker and then of
course um lower down
on the on the field margin where they
have access to much more soil
we see that um the trees are doing much
much better so understanding those
thresholds for damage
to damage is is really um important it
would to
take that information and apply it in
implant selection
uh literature and decisions
so i suppose a key question that we we
would want to ask ourselves
is how the trees cope with that limited
water availability
and so a scheme that
uh i think is helpful to to look at is
the avoidance of a particular water
deficit
and the tolerance of a water deficit and
that they're really the
two major ways in which trees can
can deal with that stress of course some
plants
could be said to escape water deficits
altogether
they have very short life cycles but of
course trees are
perennial so they can either avoid it or
tolerate it
and the avoidance is largely brought
about either by
maximizing the acquisition of water
or by reducing the water use and i
like to think of it as sort of three
major themes
in terms of the way in which trees can
do that so we have some physiological
some structural or
you might call the morpho anatomical or
life cycle approaches to those achieving
those ends
so in terms of maximizing walk water
acquisition
well the hydraulic conductivity
particularly within the roots for
example can be increased that's
been evidenced in some cases but perhaps
uh
most significantly in trees in their
natural environments
is the deep rooting ability of some
trees and
indeed in in savannah's we have found
trees with uh roots over 60 meters deep
so this ability to be able to to root
very deeply
means that you can decouple the
precipitation
on the surface from the experience
of the tree in terms of its water
deficit because if the trees can
root down into
aquifers underneath the surface and deep
water channels
then let's say they can remove the need
for
precipitation for much of the year
of course the other way to to avoid that
water deficit building up is to reduce
water use and they do that primarily
through things like stomatal closure
at a physiological level the structural
level there can be some
increased resistance to leaf water loss
a reduction in
leaf and stem growth reducing the demand
from the crown
for water but also from a life cycle
approach we have
leaf phenology whereby we have drought
deciduous
plants particularly mediterranean
climates of course where the period of
peak stress if you like for the for the
tree is during the summer drought
and so trees will lose loose leaves
during that period and ultimately of
course
leaf abscission can be a way to avoid
the deficit as well
from a um urban point of view though i
think
it is right we're interested much more
so in the tolerance
of water deficits and um things
like osmotic adjustment and the the
turbo loss point are really important to
understand
uh if work to understand how how
tolerant
trees may be to the water deficits and
lastly the the resistance to
drought-induced
cavitation or embolism is important and
again
some of these things we can quantify
quite precisely
so there are important characteristics
to look at
i suppose the you know
a good place to start is to say well
avoid the avoiders for challenging sites
we look at um this himalayan birch stuck
in a sort of
cubic meter of soil and this is
early august it should be in full leaf
and doing really
really nicely but of course the leaves
have
been shed to reduce the demand of the
crown
um for water
and so this is surely not what the
landscape architect
would have wanted or designed into that
particular scheme
other relatively sensitive trees even if
they're established in
uh you know continuous soil trenches and
in rather you know pretty good
conditions
under drought can demonstrate quite
significant leaf habitation so
we see on the on the right hand image
there that the lime trees
uh shedding their leaves this is in in
early july again they should be
absolutely in
full full leaf and doing well but that
extensive leaf shedding as a result of
drought and it
sort of could almost be autumn
underneath that particular avenue
yet if we turn around 180 degrees what
we see
along the same avenue is a different
species in this case
norway maple that's doing rather well so
um we know that there's quite a profound
difference
across species when it comes to drought
tolerance and these can make really
meaningful differences
uh when it comes to landscape
performance as well
so having looked at some of this you
know the outlying schemes of how trees
can cope with
water deficits perhaps a more applied
question is
well how can we select for drought
tolerance
and we we might take a look at the
academic plant
stress literature of course things like
jacob levitt's book
is seminal in this area those of uh you
that they're watching with
should we say perhaps a little bit more
experience
will be very familiar with this i'm sure
uh
more more recently of course you know
these sorts of texts
um are you know
really important for our understanding
of plant stress
but the problem with these taxes is
while they're brilliant
in terms of identifying mechanisms and
outlining some of the science
they tend not to do a lot of comparative
work
evaluating different different species
when we take plant use literature
of course they almost go the other way
they try to take very broad views of of
different species but don't also
don't always do that terribly precisely
so the challenge is
um you know how do we
interpret advice from this sort of
literature because if we take
a single species this uh nogundo here
box sometimes called
you know crossman would say useful for
sandy dry to sterile soil
other sources say drought tolerant but
yet it's it's native along streams and
ponds
native in moist habitat but performs
well also in poor
wet or dry habitats that's
really sitting on the fence heat and
drought tolerant iso
rows along shores of permanent bodies of
water likes humid areas grows along
stream banks flood plains and swamps so
if you look at the single species from
the plant use literature you can get a
kind of
a whole range of mixed messages and
that's
quite problematic when it comes to
giving good advice
to to plant users
there's meta-analysis and ecological
literature and this is a particularly
good one
from lindemetz and valladares
where as well as doing a big metro
analysis they provide
supplementary information with about 800
species
and rank them according to their drought
shade and water logging tolerance so
that's
where you know the whole range of
ecological literature has been reviewed
and sort of synthesized
and that's really really helpful but of
course um
i should just explain the table here
this is their their drought tolerance
ranking they have a scale ranking of one
to five and
essentially it goes from you know very
wet
areas of annual precipitation through to
through to dry
with um corresponding you know increases
in variation
in terms of when the the precipitation
is distributed in the year
the precipitation to potential
evapotranspiration
moving from rather high to to very low
and so on so you get
you know effectively a gradient that's
that's backed up by some
quantitative numbers in terms of the
drought tolerance and it's
it's all based on tree survivorship
within those areas and and the problem
is
when we look at the sort of more you
know ecological literature is i think
there has to be a question mark over
how relevant it is always to the urban
environment because if we um
place trees that have a propensity for
deep rooting
in an urban environment above a car park
or or something like that then of course
we've removed their ability to deep root
um away and so therefore they're having
to rely on other mechanisms which
just may not be there for their drought
tolerance and so
the question you know is
does survival in the environment equal
performance in our urban landscapes
and so trying to resolve how we can take
some of these things
forward we've started to look at a more
trait-based ascent
assessment and that's you know a
quantifiable characteristic
that you know can reveal something of
the tree's personality if you like and
and two particular traits of interest
are the the tergalos point
and the stem water potential at 50 loss
of hydraulic conductivity
i'm probably only going to talk a little
bit about uh the turgot loss point
in this presentation but please do ask
me about um
the loss of hydraulic conductivity in
the questions if you're particularly
interested in that
so the leaf turbo loss point is quite a
well established physiological measure
of drought tolerance and megan bartlett
has done some really good
um analysis of these turbo loss points
across the literature
and the method that that we've used and
i say we
myself a colleague henrikh harman who
was doing a
postdoc at cornell with nina um
several years ago now we used this uh
technique that was established by megan
bartlett and
her colleagues to effectively
you measure the osmotic potential at
full tiger
and then you apply a regression equation
uh
to that osmotic potential at full terga
to
estimate the leaf turbo loss point and
when you take the data that's been
published and that's actually
it's a re-analysis of some of megan
bartlett's data
megan bartlett had a global data set and
and we sort of reanalyzed just the
mediterranean and temperate
um species and we've got a slightly
better relationship
r squared of 0.91 so we use
that relationship to
uh predict our leaf turbo loss point
from the osmotic potential at forbes
erga
and then of course once we have that
we can rank species according to their
drought tolerance and so i'm just going
to
talk through a little bit of a case
study on that i should say
um prior to this new technique using
the osmometer um you'd use probably
pressure volume curves would be the most
um
most widely used technique to establish
these sorts of relationships and
we've actually since looked at
the pv technique versus uh well the vap
the vap pro which is a west core
instrument and the wp-4c
which is a decagon instrument that
effectively use
um similar techniques and we can see
that actually
the osmometers are much more sensitive
to uh osmotic potential and therefore
predicting the leaf turbulence point
than the pressure volume curves
and this was a little a study done by uh
colleague john the banks and myself
on on acers
so uh back to cornell and henrik
harmon's
postdoctoral work there with nino we
selected acer because
we understood them to be
quite variable in their tolerance to
drought and
so using the collections that call now
henrik evaluated the the leaf turbo loss
of about 26 aces species
both in the spring and the summer so we
had some indication of
seasonal adjustment of the turquoise
and so the figure that you're looking at
there shows the uh
the species we evaluated and the they're
ranked according to their summer toga
loss point so the
the most negative uh of course uh
turgolos is most drought tolerant so we
see
right the way ace of spacation going
right down to
especially and what we found
was that obviously there were really
substantive differences
across that data set and things like
aces picartan that
grow in the humid understory they had
the turtle lost point of about minus 1.6
megapascals
isotropin that would naturally grow
in an environment like this in the
chingling mountains in china
they had a turtle loss point of minus
2.4 megapascals remember
uh the data that we're getting is all
from
the trees in the botanical collection
around cornell university so
um we haven't gone to their native sites
these are all effectively in the same
botanical collection
asa tataracum though um which would
ordinarily grow the steps of
eastern romania at the turbulence point
of minus 3.6 megapascals
asa granted in the tartan uh
in the west coast of the west western
sort of slopes of the rockies
predominantly
they that was around minus 3.8
megapascals and
asymmetry you know that was even more
negative than that was around -4
and we we established that you could
pick up differences in drought tolerance
in cultivars so asus sakaram and nasa
ruben we tested multiple cultivars and
there were differences that were
statistically significant
amongst those as well and so
if you took your little planting beds in
this case this is actually a picture of
downtown ithaca so i guess
you will recognize this and whether or
not these trees are still there i don't
know
but if you took our scheme and say well
okay we're going to take those
those species with a high turbo loss
point and try and put them in these
rather constrained
um coffins if you like urban soil
coffins
um then they're not going to
work terribly well but if you if you
take a species with a much lower
more negative total loss point i'm not
saying that those species of that
are circled would be appropriate but it
you know as a general idea
if you take the the more negative turtle
or species they're going to be able to
cope much more effectively with
more extensive soil drying and so on
so since that initial case study we
we've done probably about 200 species
now so we have
quite a good range of of uh
of species good range of genre and we're
able to put the sort of framework around
it and so
what we've started looking at for our
plant
guidance and plants use guidance
is using sort of
thresholds of the turbulence point to
allocate a qualitative drought tolerance
so for example
and i think um that's less than minus
two points sorry
lesson is higher than minus 2.5
megapascals we're calling
drought sensitive between minus 2.5
and three we're calling moderately
sensitive between um
three and minus 3.5 moderately tolerant
and then
more negative than minus 3.5 tolerance
so that
we can begin to to put some um
numbers behind our qualitative terms
because
so much of the plant use literature is
is just kind of
personal interpretations and uh and so
on and that's that's okay
to an extent but if we can try and
underpin some of these qualitative terms
with
quantitative plant data then
and that's um really really helpful i
think
and so since uh we we've got these
you know rather large data sets now
we've been able to most recently done
some
some uh analysis at the the genre level
and we show that you know magnolia
bachelor you know they're really
sensitive as a genre compared with uh
groups like acer and quercus and then
you know lots of kind of
other genres will sit in the middle
somewhere but it's it's quite helpful to
to think about that and of course
um it's it's really important
to look at this individual species as
well but we can see some tendencies you
know that magnolias
at least of the 30 31 species we've
we've measured have all been really
rather sensitive
um to to drought so you know
understanding
this is is quite important and then if
we evaluate the turbo loss point that
we'd be measuring against
tolerance scales like the nintendo
validaires
scale we can see that although you know
there's not a great predictive value
there
there's a clear you know uh decrease in
the turbo loss point
uh when when the the ecological
drought tolerance scale is increasing so
again this is this is all quite helpful
supporting information
and we've been able to integrate this
into
professional guidance this is something
that came out of a project a year or so
ago
now but this is some digital guidance
that you can download for free from an
organization called the trees and design
action group which is
uh www.tdag.org uk
and you can you can go and you can
download a file
and an associated database
from that site and it it has
you know about 280 profiles
of which you know there's various items
of information that you would expect in
that in the plant use
in plant use guidance of course some of
which is
is the drought tolerance work and
wherever possible
we've we've underpinned those drought
tolerance scores
with uh quantitative trait data
but we've what we've done is interpret
that
for the reader so that you're not
presenting landscape architects or
horticulturalists
necessarily with a turtle loss value
you're
presenting them with something that
would indicate whether it's moderately
tolerant or moderately sensitive
so that it becomes usable from their
point of view but hopefully
as evidence evidence-based as it as it
possibly can be
and one of the things we we look at
doing is
in this guidance is is to identify
particular use potentials
and so for example the paved sites all
have a
moderate uh a moderate tolerance
to drought um allocated to them so those
species that we're recommending for for
page environments have this
moderate tolerance to drought or they're
tolerant to drought
and so that just helps you know
justify why we think those species are
particularly
useful for for that paved environment
i'm aware that uh you know the title of
this slide suggested that
we were going to look at waterlogging
tolerance as well and so
i also wanted to talk a little bit about
such what we call
sustainable drainage systems
and of course that involves a degree of
water locking tolerance and so
while it's um important that we have
traits that look at drought torrents
when we're
when we're evaluating water intolerance
it's um
really rather different so again
ideally we'd have some sort of scheme
you know from sensitive to tolerant
but trying to to get a handle on
how we might allocate different species
to a scheme like this
is is much more challenging than it is
for drought actually
and that's partly because flooding and
if you like water logging is a really
complex stress so there's variation
in response according to growing season
flooding death duration of
flooding time since last flood so the
recovery time since last flood
and there's you know a whole range of
metabolic uh
effects uh that can
come into play so it's quite challenging
to to really quantitatively
measure waterlogging tolerance
in a way that we can can do quite
readily through
turbo loss or the loss of hydraulic
conductance
with the drought so one of the things
that i've
we've been trying to you know develop is
is a more quantitative way to evaluate
waterlogging tolerance and so
what i turned to was sat flow
why because it provides continuous data
or more or less continuous data so we
have
something around you know every
every 10 minutes having a data set for
that
and it's sensitive to the atmospheric
conditions of course
and as well as the adaptic conditions so
it
integrates the root system in the crown
really rather nicely so you can see here
the
vpd the vapor pressure deficit and
versus the sap velocity and
this is actually in some prunus machia
and you can see where it's cool
um has high relative humidity and it
rains
we get depressed sap velocities where
it's
relatively warm low relative humidity
much higher sap losses and you can see
the really
incredible association between the
press pressure deficit and the sat
velocity
so uh that's
i should just explain you know every
peak represents a day and you can see
the
the upright grey bars there there
um then the night time so you can see
these oscillations
between day day sat sat flow and
much much lower or zero sat flow at
night
and so i used this technique and i took
a range of species and i'll just
share three with you this is prunus
macchiato
as a type of cherry that's related to
siberia
and when we impose a water logging
stress on it you can see that
very rapidly that
waterlogging treatment departs from the
control treatment
there's n equals six here um and that
the gray banding
represents the standard error so you can
see you get a decline
really rather rapidly with the
the waterlogging period and then when i
i've drained
drained the containers
actually that doesn't get any worse but
it
sticks at around the 50 percent level
if that makes sense and so we we flooded
them
we drained them at peak stress there was
no physical
sorry no visible differences between
those
those two treatments they looked exactly
the same yet there was massive
differences occurring
to the sap flow and if we look at sat
flow versus
the photosynthesis and stomatal
conductance we see that
you know very rapidly we get a decline
in
photosynthesis and stomata conductance
uh in that waterlogging period and then
even during the drained period the
certainly after the first week the
the gas exchange hadn't really recovered
to any great extent
and we look at another species ace
platinoides this
is uh again the daily sat flow so you
can see the peaks and troughs
going on with that it's waterlogged
and very very rapidly we see this
decline
in in sap flow in the waterlogg
treatment
and you can you can again see at peak
peak water logging stress no difference
at all in the
um visible symptoms
when we drained it though i was quite
surprised to see that actually
what happened was uh they totally
defoliated
and uh yeah by the end you can see that
such massive differences in sat flow
as a result of the the waterlogged trees
having totally
defoliated and they lost their
they lost their their leaves and
therefore their demand for
the water from the roots so we can see
that the
the isoplatinoid is very sensitive to
water logging and the phosphine cysts
and somatoconductance
absolutely crashed as a result
so let's contrast this to a species that
should be tolerant to waterlogging
salix alba so this is a white willow i'm
sure you have plenty of
tolerant willows
and you can see during that water
logging phase
there is really rather minor differences
between the two
treatment groups
that they rained a lot so you can see
almost no
no uh safflow on that day and then when
we drained
you know again we don't really see any
profound
differences between the between the
treatments
it's a bit it was a bit dark and wet
while i did this and the
sensors were on on solar panels so
that's why we lost about a day's worth
um of data there but you get the idea
that much
much much less response from the
tolerant
uh species to the to the sensitive
species
so again you know we water logged and
although we did pick up a reduction
in photosynthesis and stomata
conductance after a week's
waterlogging uh within the within
the following week after being drained
was no difference
whatsoever in in the in the treatment
groups
one of the reasons that of course willow
is
is waterlogging tolerant is the presence
of hypertrophic blood cells and you
could see those clearly developing
underneath the water line and that of
course helps to ventilate
the the root system
and and is one of the reasons why why
yes
celix are pretty tolerant to
waterlogging
so from that study you know i think
we were able to demonstrate that sat
flow could be used as a tool to evaluate
water logging tolerance there seemed to
be at least three but possibly more
responses to the to the sat flow
one no relatively no response really
a decline in in sap flow throughout the
waterlogging period and then sort of
stabilizing
upon drainage and then the decline
throughout the waterlogging period and
then
continue to climb after draining
probably as a result of
what we would call post-anoxic stress
where whereby
the root system is re-oxygenated and
that can release a lot of
toxins and it seems that aceplatenoids
was particularly
susceptible to that because it lost its
leaves
of course photosynthesis and somatic
inductance are also very sensitive to
water logging
and basically visual analysis is useless
for identifying this particular
stress because in all cases
although because we're going to see
profound physiological changes in
saffron gas exchange
visually there was really very little to
choose between the different
treatments so i think that's an
important message
for us as applied scientists if you're
out inspecting trees if there's been
water logging events
there may be some profound things going
on that you just can't pick up recently
so i would hope then in terms of the
the future of tree selection we would be
able to provide a little bit more
foresight and one of the ways which we
can do that is
by collecting data through plant traits
and integrating that
more effectively into our
plant selection literature and that's
going to be really important for
providing climate resilience and so
biosecurity as well
integrate much more evidence-based
approaches
and focus on landscape performance not
just
on landscape as aesthetic and i think
that's going to be really key as
as we move forward into more challenging
times
and hopefully um you know we can support
and enable scientists to carry out some
of this work
and translate knowledge so that it
doesn't just
stay in the academic realm some of this
this knowledge
really gets out into the landscape
and professional plant use communities
because of course
it's not much good unless it does that
so i think that's probably where i want
to
to leave it in terms of what i've got to
say i'm not sure how i'm doing
for time but i think that's not a
million miles away
um you're doing fine yeah thanks thanks
very much for your time listening
well thank you so much uh andrew we have
a little time uh
got about 10 minutes if people have
questions
[Music]
just say on mute and
[Music]
question away hi andrew
thank you so much for this interesting
talk um i was
wondering with your treatments of
flooding
is a one week time period
where did you come up with that number
is that something that you've seen in
cities that get flooded or it was kind
of arbitrary
yeah well um it's a good question where
did i come up with that number well
i guess the project was geared around um
trying to get a better handle on which
species would be good for the
sustainable drainage systems
and of course they're basically designed
to flood regularly
but probably for relatively short
periods of time during
during the season because they'll drain
very very rapidly
as well um so i just
yeah i mean i picked a week because
i i felt it would be long enough for
those that are really sensitive
to show something but not sufficiently
um difficult to to sort of
do several species in any one year i
only had i mean one
one of it's just practical reasons
really i only had 12
sat flow sensors at the time and i
wanted to sort of rotate a number of
different species over the course of the
growing season and so sort of had a um
you know
weeks kind of recovery uh weeks
stress treatment just to sort of keep
things moving so
there's so much more much more work you
could do experimenting with different
times durations of flooding short short
regular flooding periods or very
extended flooding periods
but i just um it was quite exploratory
in that sense so i just saw
yeah just went for a week and that's
what happened yeah
sorry i can't be more more kind of
scientific than that but that's
yeah that was basically the decision
makes total sense thank you so andrew us
i wonder also about the flooding in
terms of the seasonality of flooding
when it happens i mean because there are
normal floodplain species that
get flooded in the spring and do fine
but when you do the flooding in the
summer or later summer
they don't do as well and so i wonder if
you thought about the seasonality of
flooding
well again um we def
seasonality definitely does make a a big
difference
uh when it comes to the species
responses
um lots of things can cope quite well
with
uh winter water logging but it's as
summer waterlogging poses a much more
significant problem to them
and as you say some can cope well with
the
spring flooding because they're used to
dealing with snowmelt or whatever it
might be and seasonal
more seasonal um i think
you know all that work is is yet to be
done so if somebody wants to
uh to look at that um you know that
would be fantastic i suppose
to say what i was hoping to do was just
demonstrate that sap flow could be
a useful tool to evaluate the
sensitivity to flooding
um because it sort of integrates so many
other signals
right thank you yeah challenging
study uh nina can i ask
questions hey andrew um
really enjoyed your seminar uh the work
on waterlogging
is really interesting it's it's very
obvious that
sap flow can be used as an indicator
here
but when you use compared with just
traditional gas exchange
um when you set flow you have to take
the candidate tree canopy size into
consideration
so if these two trees are quite
different in size
that would be reflected in the sep flow
correct
yes yeah
okay yeah i mean these were all um the
the trees that i used were all supplied
at the same
size in the same soil volume
so so and i had n equals six
um which is believe it or not is
relatively good for sat flow studies
often you just get one or two replicas
um
because there is yeah absolutely there's
variation according to
uh from tree from tree to tree and that
is that is important to
acknowledge um and
yeah we if i plotted individual trees
out rather than the mean
you see that variation so it's important
to have sufficient replication to
you know be able to uh deal with that um
but it's good no again it's a good point
you definitely have to acknowledge that
and if you were doing it i suppose in
the field you'd need to
you know in a sort of natural site that
would be
much much more challenging to control
for but i just had uh
the same size trees from uh from the
nursery so there were
it was variation but perhaps less i mean
the other the other way you can get
variation is just some
installation artifacts you know these
these sensors aren't absolutely
foolproof for sure
so um you can get installation artifacts
and things like that
kind of artificially skew some data
yeah so it's not it's not bulletproof um
but i think if if done carefully it's
quite a useful technique
yeah and it gives you the whole tree
picture
yeah exactly because
yeah i mean you saw how well it sort of
um mapped up to
the vapor pressure deficit um that was
uh
really very closely related every little
sort of
peak and trough could be related to
changes in vapor pressure deficit and
that's
that's the other thing you know you you
need to have a handle on
what's going on atmospherically um and
with a control
group because there's so much variation
across that flow
unless you unless you understood those
things you wouldn't
you couldn't hope to say that it's down
to a treatment effect
yeah thank you um i i do have another
question
andrew could you elaborate
a little more on the method um
you used to determine the water
potential
at loss of turker because i remember
tom whitlow was using i mean in the old
days
uh you know spending a lot of time doing
pv curves and things like that
but the method you developed and they
have used
is uh obviously a lot simpler
yeah yeah yeah so i mean i i should say
i didn't develop technique it was megan
bartlett's um
[Music]
but yeah we i thought this is a rather
handy technique because
um you know pv curves anyone that's done
them will probably have a
love-hate relationship with them because
they're extremely time consuming or can
be
um and so what this this the technique
that we did we went out and to the
collections uh we harvested
relatively small shoots from
from different individual replicas
and then we would re-cut under water
so that we would removed any sort of
embolism as a result of taking the
initial cut
and then we would rehydrate overnight
in a dark cool chamber with very high
relative humidity
so that the leaves or the shoots i
should say
were back at full turgot because
otherwise you have effects as a result
of relative water content
and um so so after that we would then
take uh like a
you know like a hole punch effectively
take a small leaf disk
and place that into the osmometer and
the osmometer
um then takes a value which you convert
into the
water potential um these things are
designed for looking at bloods and
urines and so on in hospital but they
they effectively do that do they
do the job so um yeah so that was so it
was
yeah basically harvesting shoots
rehydrating overnight
oh sorry i missed out to say we had to
flash flash freeze in liquid nitrogen
in order to remove remove the turbo
pressure element so that the water
potential that was being measured in the
leaf disc
was only relating to the osmotic
potential not a combination of
osmotic and turbine does that make sense
yeah yes thanks we uh
uh brandon and i are doing work with
that so anytime we want to
come by and see what uh we're doing with
the osmotic potential
with the vapor pressure uh osmometer
let's get together yeah thank you nina
i'm just wondering what tree species you
uh expect to see more of in
the future urban planning and
environments
um well
i i think probably a greater focus on
the more drought tolerant species would
be certainly there so
um i think about the the things like the
ace of mon pessilanum which
was shown to be very drought tolerant
and uh
is almost exactly the same as something
that gets
basic and pestering which gets planted
very very widely
over here and there's in some ways a con
a continuation
um of the a basic competitory population
uh into sort of uh central europe
uh i think you know shift shifting from
mesa camp history
to asim one peso things like that you
know we'll see little
little nudges where as
landscape kind of also the general
public probably won't notice much
difference but there will be
tweaks to the species profiles that will
need a slightly more drought tolerant i
think there's lots of examples like that
which you can point to
and of course diversity
in species is also
going to be really important with that
diversity coming from
the more stress-tolerant species
but i guess it will depend a lot on
where you are what's available in in the
nurseries around you and so on
and i'm sure nina's got lots of other
examples that she she could offer you
yeah i love uh my special elena but it's
basically a
big shrub yeah well that is true i think
there are there are that there is some
some were trying to get sort of more
standard tree
type um on pestilence but you're right
yeah unless
if you certainly if you grow up from
seeds chances are you're gonna get a big
shrub yeah
um so yeah that's that's perhaps
that that's true i think there there are
some there are some tree forms that you
can get from
from the german nurseries for sure worth
looking at
yeah okay if there's no more questions
okay well we will thank andrew heartily
for this fascinating seminar and good to
see you again andrew and uh
uh thank you so much for joining us it's
a pleasure well thanks for all your
your time and um yeah i appreciate you
taking
time out to sign in and um yeah and
if you want to follow up uh with me on
the one-to-one or
uh you can send me an email that's no
problem at all
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu